hurricane Harvey dumped a record amount
of rain on Texas but about 150 flooded
out families say their troubles were
man-made residents of Sweeney Texas say
floodwaters were knowingly forced into
their neighborhoods when a local oil
refinery in a chemical plant dammed up
to bayous the Army Corps of engineer is
investigating mark Strassmann spoke to
families who live near the plants and
lost their homes and he's in sweeney
that's southwest of Houston mark good
morning good morning David and Lisa Hart
Quist live here this house and the 20
acres it sits on was their retirement
plan but as you can see it is flooded
into ruin a disaster they believe was
both needless and preventable it was
about this deep so wait I for 13 days
after Harvey
David Harr quiz house was an island you
can't imagine I've got pictures and you
look at it and it's like good god
there's no dry ground anywhere but the
hark was say disaster struck after the
storm had moved on flood waters stopped
receding and began rising again this
time into the house it was like a pond
out here riah puzzled I was I was
shocked I was like what in the world is
going on and then all sudden the water
came up and it started coming up quickly
heart quits needed this kayak to feed
his stranded animals he lost much of his
house his farming equipment and
livestock a quarter million dollar loss
was like living in a big sewer the water
stunk it was nasty it was dirty about
four miles away the Phillips 66 refinery
sits next to the Chevron Phillips
chemical plant a lawsuit filed by about
150 families claims by damming to nearby
bayous without warning the companies
knowingly pushed flood water away from
the plant and into neighborhoods you can
see in this video shot days later the
plant to the right appears dry while
homes to the left are under water it was
full I mean up here it was almost to the
top of the where we're standing right
now lawyer Josh Boland represents the
families now suing the two companies
he showed us one spot that was dammed
and shared with us this video of the
backhoe that was used
remove the blockage I've talked to so
many people but if they just would had a
little bit of notice they could have
saved so much and there's mold
everywhere everywhere this is what's
left of Tim and Melissa Foster's dream
house nothing but buckled floors and
runaway mold they've ruined our dream
this was our dream and it's gone Tim
works as a technician at Chevron
Phillips the fosters have joined the
lawsuit against his employer it said an
odd position to be in
oh it's a very awkward position to be in
I mean every day I go to work I question
will this be my last day
Chevron Phillips did not respond to
repeated requests for comment but in a
statement Phillips 66 said our
priorities during the flood were to
protect people and the environment we do
not believe these actions on one side of
our property impacted the ongoing
flooding event adjacent to the refinery
or in the community apologize for the
profanity but that's a bunch of
straight-up they made a conscious
decision to save their plant but those
actions have consequences and they need
to be held responsible for those actions
the refinery told us the plant also got
some flooding that damaged equipment
both the heart quiz and the Fosters did
have flood insurance but they have yet
to hear a response to their claims
Gail very very much thank you mark
important reminder people still need
help even though the rains have stopped
pain still continues there thanks a lot